- Welcome back.
(audience applauds)
This is a "Welcome to
Chippendales" takeover.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
I am Kumail Nanjiani,
and I'm here with my
co-stars of the series,
Quentin Plair, Annaleigh Ashford,
Murray Bartlett.
(audience applauds)
- Wait wait wait wait,
- Can I just, can I
just try one more time?
I really think it's
gonna happen this time.
- Okay. All right.
- Welcome to The Chippendale's Takeover.
(cowbell bangs)
(audience applauds)
(rock music)
- Yeah!
(Quentin laughing)
- Are you okay?
(crowd cheering)
Are you okay?
- That was amazing, yes. Wow.
- You went full superstar.
- [Kumail] Wow. Maybe, yeah.
- I went Molly Shannon.
(audience laughing)
- Maybe if you did that the first time,
they would've played.
- So, in Welcome to Chippendales,
which is now streaming on Hulu.
We spend a lot of time around dancers
who don't wear a lot of clothes.
We have some of those dancers here today,
so it's time to see what they've got!
This is a brand new game.
(audience cheering)
We're playing a brand new
game for Kelly's show,
it's called "What Dances
Go With These Pantses."
♪ What Dances go with these Pantses ♪
- Here to host is a very funny man.
You can see them in the film "Bros",
as well as in the upcoming season
of the award-winning
series "Hacks" on HBO.
Please say hello to Guy Branum!
(audience cheering)
(rock music)
- Guy, buddy. Good to see you.
- Hello, Kumail.
- Guy. Would you explain the game to us?
- Of course, I will, Kumail.
Uh, this game features five dancers.
One at a time, they will
walk out to their platform
with their breakaway pants.
I will tell them to "remove those pants".
You guys have to help me
though when it happens.
(audience cheering)
And they will reveal
their themed underpants.
If you know the name of the dance
that goes with those underpants,
hit your button and yell out your answer.
You will get bonus points for enthusiasm
if you dance along.
I will be the judge.
If you're wrong,
the other team does have
the option of stealing.
The teams are Kumail and Murray
versus Quentin and Annaleigh.
- Yes
- [Guy] All right, let's
get those dancer's out here!
(audience cheering)
Okay. Where are they? Where
do they come out from?
- Where do they come?
Let's get our first dancer out here!
(audience cheering)
(rock music)
- All right. Come on, Daxton!
- All right, dancer number one!
Remove those pants!
(funky music)
- Oh, oh oh!
- YMCA!
- Kumail Nanjiani, what is it?
- You gotta dance it!
- YMCA!
- Yeah!
(bell dings)
- I messed up the end.
- That was, it was fine.
Kumail's was perfunctory,
It was workman-like
Murray, you at least had
notes of homosexuality,
I was excited to see it.
I'm giving you one points
for a correct answer
and one point for enthusiasm.
(bell dings)
Thank you so much, dancer number one!
[Murray]- Oh my god, we got one!
[Guy]- Yes!
All right, let's get the
next dancer out here!
(rock music)
Dancer number two,
could you remove those pants!
(upbeat music)
- Annaleigh Ashford!
- Aerobics! Aerobics! Aerobics!
- Aerobics!
- That was flash dance,
that kind of thing?
I guess we have a bucket
of water to splash on him?
[Annaleigh]- Yes.
[Quentin]- Yes! Jennifer Lopez.
[Guy]- All right.
- Wait, she didn't do the
dance while answering!
[Guy]- Hold on, hold on.
- I mean, that's aerobics,
can you give us more flash dance?
Can you give us more?
Yes, exactly. Exactly.
- Yes! Okay, that was good.
- That's beautiful. One
point for a correct answer,
(bell dings)
two points for enthusiasm!
Thank you, dancer number two!
Next dancer, come on out!
(sultry music)
- Yeah!
- All right, Bruce!
- Dancer number three,
remove those pants!
(soft music)
- Oh!
- Murray Bartlett! Murray Bartlett!
Murray Bartlett came in-
- It's flamenco!
- All right, Bartlett, flamenco for us.
(crowd cheering)
Oh, that's beautiful theatricality!
- Yes!
- Thank you.
- Wonderful work, Murray Bartlett!
One point for a correct answer,
Two points for enthusiasm.
(bell dings)
- Thank you, thank you.
- We've got five over here,
three over here.
Thank you so much, dancer number three!
(crowd cheering)
Come on out, dancer number four!
(rock music)
(crowd cheering)
Dancer number four,
could you remove those pants!
(disco music)
- That's disco!
- Annaleigh Ashford! Annaleigh Ashford!
- Disco! Disco! Disco!
- Disco, that is correct!
(bell dings)
- Here, spin me.
- Oh, okay. Oh, oh-
Woo!
- Quentin, she is carrying you
on her shoulders right now!
That is one point for a correct answer,
Two points for enthusiasm,
(bell dings)
but I wanna see more from you.
- I'm sorry.
- Thank you so much, dancer
number four! (crowd cheering)
- We're gonna do it! Are
you guys ready to go?
- Yeah, let's go!
- Yes.
- All right, come on
out, dancer number five!
(rock music)
(crowd cheering)
[Annaleigh]- Yes, my king!
[Kumail]- Woo!
- All right, dancer number five!
Could you remove those pants!
(groovy music)
- Yo! MC Hammer!
- Oh yes!
- What's up!
- Correct answer.
(bell dings)
- Yeah!
(horn blows)
- Quentin, you finally came alive for us!
- And almost fell.
- That's one point for a correct answer,
three points for enthusiasm,
(bell dings)
and the win!
- Yes!
- Congratulations!
[Annaleigh]- We won!
That DJ air horn means time is up,
and the big winners today
are Annaleigh and Quentin!
- Yes!
- Although you guys did not
technically beat Kelly Clarkson,
your photos will still-
you beat her champion,
you, your photos will still be mounted,
but with an asterisk on the
chick's wall of champs.
[Quentin]- What?
[Guy]- Congratulations.
- We're gonna be on the wall!
- Okay? I'll take it.
- All right, well, thank you
for hosting, Guy, this game that I lost,
(Guy laughing)
and you lost with me.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
Once again, you can see Guy
Branum in the upcoming season
of Hacks on HBO,
and do not forget to watch
"Welcome to Chippendales" on Hulu!